en este vídeo vamos a hablar sobre este
fantástico número que es el a la j omega
t y algo genial que vamos a hacer es
usar todo lo que sabemos sobre números
complejos esta forma exponencial de
números complejos y senos y cosenos como
función del tiempo y vamos a finalizar
con la idea de un número que gira
creo que esto es algo genial con
respecto a la electrónica y es la
esencia de la teoría de procesamiento de
señales
este número de acá y al aj por omega t
se basa en la fórmula de hoy leer y
recordemos que la fórmula de hoy leer es
que a la jota por teta que es nuestra
variable es igual a coseno detecta más j
por el seno de teta esta es una forma de
la fórmula de hoy leer la otra forma es
con el negativo en el exponente es la
menos jt está igual a coseno detectan
menos jota por el seno de teta si
gráfica mos esto va a lucir más o menos
así sí gráfica mos esto en un plano
complejo que es un plano que tiene un
eje real y un eje imaginario
ahora recordemos que j es la variable
que usamos para indicar la unidad
imaginaria j al cuadrado es igual a
menos 1 y la usamos en ingeniería
eléctrica en lugar de la y una forma de
expresar este número es graficándolo en
este plano complejo
si yo ubico un número complejo en este
plano por ejemplo aquí y dijo que la
coordenada horizontal es este coseno de
teta y este valor en el eje vertical es
el seno de teta
y si dibujo una línea hacia nuestro
número este será el ángulo theta así que
esta es una representación de los
números complejos y así también podemos
graficar esta fórmula de hoy leer en su
forma exponencial así que podemos
representarla así también sé que esta
anotación es un poco complicada al ver
esto no puedo evitar ver que tenemos una
exponencial que se eleva a un número
imaginario y todo lo que yo sé sobre
exponencial es como que me confunde con
esto pero con el tiempo lo que he
aprendido a hacer es decir bueno tengo
el elevado a cualquier cosa toda esa
cosa es un número complejo y es así como
luce un número complejo así que veamos
algunas propiedades de este número
complejo una de las cosas que nos
podemos preguntar es cuál es la magnitud
de esta es elevado a la jota por theta
ponemos nuestro símbolo de magnitud de
aquí y esto significa cuál es el valor
que tiene esto está r y podemos
calcularla usando el teorema de
pitágoras sabemos que esto al cuadrado
va a ser igual
el valor horizontal al cuadrado que es
el coseno más el valor vertical al
cuadrado que es seno es igual al coseno
cuadrado de teta más el seno cuadrado de
teta
acabamos de aplicar el teorema de
pitágoras ya que este es un triángulo
rectángulo nosotros por trigonometría
sabemos cuál es el valor de esto el
coseno al cuadrado más el seno al
cuadrado para cualquier ángulo siempre
va a ser igual a 1 y esto nos dice que
la magnitud de el elevado a la jota por
theta al cuadrado va a ser igual a 1 o
que la magnitud del elevado a la jota
por theta va a ser igual a 1 también así
que lo escribimos la magnitud de la jota
por theta es igual a 1 si regresamos
aquí arriba esperamos que la longitud de
este vector que es un número complejo
está a una distancia de una unidad a
partir del origen así que sabemos que la
magnitud de a la jota por theta es igual
a 1 de hecho podemos ir acá y dibujar un
círculo más o menos así aquí tenemos el
círculo unitario cuyo radio es igual a 1
así que yo sé que para cualquier valor
de e
j por theta va a estar en algún lugar de
este círculo amarillo de este círculo
amarillo así que a la j por theta va a
estar en algún lugar de este círculo
amarillo y el ángulo teta esto que está
aquí va a ser igual a cualquier cosa que
esté multiplicando a jota aquí en el
exponente cualquier cosa que esté
multiplicando a jota va a ser el ángulo
theta y qué tal si yo quisiera algo que
no se encuentra en el círculo unitario
algo que esté más alejado del origen
pues lo que voy a hacer es tomar a que
es una amplitud cualquiera multiplicada
por el elevado a la jota por theta y
esta amplitud va a expandir la longitud
de este vector si yo quisiera saber qué
tan lejos está la magnitud de la jota
por theta es 1 y la magnitud de a esa
así que esto es igual a aa si yo fuera a
dibujar un círculo para esto
digo que es un poco más grande que uno y
esto de aquí tendrá un valor de a el
radio de este círculo será igual a a
es una notación bastante flexible y con
esta anotación podremos representar
cualquier número en el plano complejo
con este formato de aquí hasta aquí
vamos a llegar en este vídeo en el
siguiente vídeo cambiaremos theta por un
argumento que tiene que ver con el
tiempo y vamos a ver qué sucede con esta
exponencial compleja